here with reaction former vice president
of the united states
mike pence is back with us sir welcome
back it's great to see you thank you
uh i'd like to have the adults back in
action and working that would be good
let me let me start with this question
did you ever imagine
in our lifetime
that we would ever see
a
president of the united states because i
know you wouldn't do it i know donald
trump wouldn't do it i know mike pompeo
wouldn't do it
abandoned fellow americans
13 days after promising that he wouldn't
abandon any any americans you ever see
that happening
let me just be very clear on this
point sean for your viewers
the biden administration's disastrous
withdrawal from afghanistan
was the greatest foreign policy debacle
since the iran hostage crisis and it
never had to happen
the deal that our administration
negotiated
uh actually uh was was finished in
february of 2020. that was just a matter
of weeks
after president trump had given the
order to take out qasim salamani it was
just a few months
after we had
eliminated the isis caliphate and taken
down abu bakr al-baghdadi and the
president made it clear and i was in the
oval office when he was speaking to
mulla baradar
that they would either keep the deal to
work with the afghan government to not
harm any american personnel in
afghanistan and not be a safe harbor for
terrorists or we would hit them harder
than we'd ever hit them before and as
evidence that they took us seriously we
went 18 months without a single american
casualty in afghanistan but weakness
arouses evil sean and there's no
question that the weakness evidenced by
the biden administration i would say
beginning when they were silent when
thousands of rockets were rained down on
our cherished ally israel from hamas
sent a signal into afghanistan that we
would not respond
and you saw as you said earlier you saw
the taliban march into mazar al-sharif
and then just simply
simply walk into kabul
and i just i i really want people to
know that i believe with all of my heart
that this never had to happen i my i
grieve for the 13 service members who
were lost karen and i prayed and spent
time with the family of corporal
lumberto sanchez from logansport indiana
uh we we
it's hard for me to say it but it just
didn't have to happen but it's just it's
an example of what weak leadership means
on the world stage
and it's such a contrast
to the to the heavy-handed
leadership of this administration at
home we have we have a president who is
weak abroad
but is very content to be lecturing the
american people about vaccine mandates
and attempting to drive through the
congress what would be not just the
largest
largest spending bill in the history of
the country sean it would be the largest
tax increase in the history of the
country that the joint taxation
committee in congress just said would
raise taxes
in just a matter of a few years
on americans who make over forty
thousand dollars a year we have got to
dig in
tell the story of what they're doing
and i truly do believe that the voice of
the american people can turn back this
massive uh
big government socialist
bill and uh and i'm doing my level
better let's get that and share the
story i want to stay on one issue first
and i have this confirmed by secretary
of state pompeo mark meadows and and
others i don't know if you heard the
calls and if you did what you can share
with us i'd like to know
that before any
deal was ever
discussed
in terms of
america's withdrawal from afghanistan
that it was made very clear by the
president donald trump that if they
don't follow every period comma dotted i
and cross t
let me be clear he said he would
obliterate them over and over again it
included a conditions on the ground base
withdrawal it included america keeping
bagram air base forever strategically
important location china
and that in fact it was said over and
over again what happened to the
caliphate solomoni al-baghdadi and
associates the al-qaeda leader in yemen
will happen to you do you understand did
you hear those calls i was standing
across
the resolute desk
from president trump
when he's talked on the speaker phone to
mula baradar of the taliban in february
2020.
and he said look uh we all want to end
the violence and and you know i share
the conviction that
the vast majority of americans believe
that we wanted we wanted to get our
troops home but we wanted to do it with
honor we wanted to do in an orderly way
and we wanted to leave behind
the kind of conditions that would be
reflective of the enormous service and
sacrifice of our troops over the last 20
years and the president made it clear he
said if you break this deal we're going
to hit you harder than we have ever hit
you before he added he said i don't like
saying that but he said i i just want
you to know and i could hear in mulla
baradar's voice
that he knew president trump meant
business and and then you see this
administration come in they moved the
the date for the withdrawal
uh beyond the spring and into the
fighting season first incomprehensibly
saying on september 11th but i have to
tell you the idea that we abandoned
bagram air base
in the middle of the night without
telling our allies
and worst of all that we left americans
and american allies behind
was unconscionable uh and and i have to
tell you that that the generals that
have been testifying before the congress
uh the focus on all the advice the
president got the american people know
the buck stops on the president's desk
and i believe that the people of this
country in the days ahead the weeks
ahead the elections ahead uh are going
to hold joe biden accountable for the
disastrous withdrawal can i say one more
thing though sean yes sir that nothing
of of the current commander-in-chief's
failings in afghanistan
and i want to say this from my heart to
every veteran who served there and the
families of our fallen
nothing of the disastrous withdrawal
from afghanistan by joe biden will ever
diminish the service and sacrifice of
all of our our service members over the
last 20 years who went to afghanistan
and defended our freedom they will be
honored forever in the annals of the
history of this country and god bless
them all
you know i look at the success the
policy success of the of of the trump
pence administration i look at it
we had energy independence for the first
time in 75 years we had the lowest
illegal immigration in almost 40 years
uh to stay in mexico policy work the
wall building work uh eliminating you
know catch and release now it's process
and release now we're going to be have a
30-year record open borders process
release
energy independence lower taxes less
bureaucracy
the economy was booming record low
unemployment for every demographic group
in the country
free and fair trade nato paying their
fair share
the world believed that
the trump administration would use force
appropriately when needed and there was
a genuine fear
and peace through strength worked
as you look back on all of these issues
all of this now in nine months has
disappeared
i knew it would be bad i tried to warn
people right i didn't think it would be
this bad this fast oh you took the words
out of my mouth john i knew it would be
bad we worked our hearts out
uh in that campaign last year but i
didn't know it would be this bad i mean
the truth is from the very first day
of the biden administration they have
been working to unravel and undo
all of the policies that resulted in a
stronger more secure more prosperous
america and this latest massive
bill going that they're trying to force
through the congress
is just the latest example of that i
mean we cut taxes
uh on working families and small
businesses and created seven million
good paying jobs we we built 400 miles
of border wall and negotiated with
mexico and remain in mexico agreement
that reduced illegal immigration by 90
now we're in the middle of the worst
border crisis
in american history on my podcast that
we just recorded today i talked to
rodney scott who was the chief of the
border patrol until about five months
ago and he said literally
from from election day forward the
rhetoric coming out of the biden harris
team was emboldening the cartels
emboldening people to begin the long and
dangerous journey north to our border
and the crisis that you see today is a
result of them unraveling our policies
that were working at the border
and the messages that they have been
sending south of the border and i i just
i have to tell you on one issue after
another i'm i'm absolutely convinced
that the american people can see that in
our administration we were putting
common sense conservative principles
into practice our nation our border was
more secure our economy more prosperous
our liberties more secure with 300
judges on our supreme on our courts and
three on the supreme court and now the
american people can see this big
government socialist agenda
writ large open borders higher taxes a
weak and apologetic foreign policy and i
got to tell you sean i know we got a
couple of elections this fall in in
places like virginia and and new jersey
and we got some big elections next year
and i think we're going to get it all
back because i think the american people
see our record
they see their record of of liberalism
and incompetence and i think the
american people are going to take the
reins turn this country around and we're
going to win back the congress in 2022
and then we're going to win back america
in 2024.
you know i know a lot has been made over
the disagreement you had with the
president as it relates to january 6.
my sources my understanding are is that
you two have a a strong relationship to
this day
what is your relationship with the
president
look you can't spend uh almost five
years in a political foxhole without
somebody without without developing a
strong relationship and
you know january 6 was a tragic day
in the history of our capital building
but
thanks to the efforts of capitol hill
police federal officials the capitol was
secured
we finished our work
and the president and i sat down a few
days later and talked through all of it
i can tell you that we parted amicably
at the end of the administration and
we've talked a number of times since we
both left office but but i believe that
our entire focus today
should be on the future i've campaigned
a couple of times for glenn younkin who
will be a great governor in the state of
virginia i've been traveling all across
this country helping our team running
for the house and the senate and i'll be
helping governors candidates around
america so i know i know the media wants
to distract from the biden
administration's failed agenda by
focusing on one day in january they want
to use that one day to try and demean
uh the the character and intentions of
74 million americans
who believed we could be strong again
and prosperous again and supported our
administration in 2016 and
in 2020 but for our part i i truly
believe we all ought to remain
completely focused on the future
that's where i'm focused and i i really
i want a commission too i believe that i
believe the future is bright i want a
commission also on the 534 riots that
took place in 2020 the ones where kamala
harris was promoting bail funds to get
the riders out that killed dozens of
americans injured thousands of police
officers pelted with bricks rocks
bottles and molotov cocktails mr vice
president we hope you come on regularly
thank you for being with us we
appreciate you being back hey sean
hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to fox news youtube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else